what was the whole experience like for
you like is there anything off camera or
anything like I really heard that I only
heard the stories you told me that was a
there was a lot of things cut cuz you we
all went there to scouted that they
before Dan yeah we happen to be in
Shinjuku and I was gonna film that the
next day and we were like we just like
rock up to this house club and see
what's up I didn't like it looks sketch
right like it was pretty oh yes they
were very very nice to me but I won't I
will be honest and say that the it was a
little you know no I mean I remember
going to the area and I'm like I'm
normally I don't fear for my safety in
Japan and a really sketchy area of
Shinjuku yeah yeah yeah and uh I mean
what what do you want to know about this
experience we were recording for four
hours okay so it was a four hour shoot
so we started before they opened up and
then we went through the whole thing and
they like the whole point was that like
I wanted I like actually try and talk to
customers yeah cuz it might had it I
wanted it to kind of be like Louis
Theroux asked where he bring he puts
himself in this yeah yeah yeah I really
wanted to put myself in a situation that
was really uncomfortable for me and uh
yeah so I was introduced around by the
main guy called tiser and I'm very
thankful he shared me around
I don't think many people in the
comments liked him there and why he made
a lot of jokes and we caught a lot of
them I was very very insistent and like
bashing my looks a lot and I was rolling
with it I was like yeah yeah do you
think do you think he was trying to be
funny and just failing or was it like
was this like that I think he was also
maybe a little light acting up for the
camera I think maybe he's like oh this
new kid comes in yeah who's got
subscribers let's show him like you know
what no way assert dominance that the
the way that they like attract women I
found was like so blatantly Jaffa be
yeah you know what I mean it's like it
was um really opposite from like West
and hitting on like they would literally
the moment this girl sat down right they
were like yo you're hot you're beautiful
what you doing oh you like what do you
do they were like the moment they sit
down they start hitting that forward
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you know those girls and the problem
is is that like they wanted me to like
sit down and immediately like start
hitting on them and I was like so like
do I can't do that - yeah but it's
restraint so like the way the hosts work
at least these guys like the whole thing
was like you know but of them up get
them to you know buy you drinks at them
online talk to them take them out on
dates and afterwards be like hey you
coming at the host club tonight like it
was really like weird I guess
superficial yeah it was very superficial
and I I really I felt understood how
like a lot of these girls were really
into them because there's one girl in
the video who was like abdomen that she
was gonna marry the host obviously he
was like yeah of course you are you know
because she just spent $10,000 on a
champagne bottle so it's gonna be like
of course you're my future did she do to
be able to afford such frivolous
expenditure what they told me off-camera
was that they tend to be in the same
kind of industry oh so it's kind of like
they're like the same five tumblr
artists just giving each other search
just giving each other the same
Commission the circular economy if you
say she might be working away most of
them were working in so plans don't know
is an under board kind of its it is if
you google it it's a process
prostitution yeah it's legal
prostitution yeah so a lot of them
tended to be also you know prostitutes
yeah and I guess that's why they were
maybe ok with the superficiality but
alright you have been to a snack bar or
hostess club or anything before that I'd
went to like a maid cafe and ass about
it anything where it was like like that
because they were like on the moment
these girls come in they get a eight or
nine minutes each each host wrote of an
hour just hit on these girls so one goes
in and then you know he does this thing
immediately after he walks the next
house comes in starts hitting on and
then after like an hour right she is who
she likes
so speed dates if literally speed dating
but a lot of the girls I think they're
coming for their cuz you get like two
hours of free like by ten bucks for all
you can drink
right so a lot of the
people a lot of people come in do the
two hours and then just never come back
yeah but yeah no I remember it was
really really really painful to try and
hit on these girls because I was trying
to hit on them through a translator I
don't know it's like it's like this
distance we're seeing that as well I'm
like you look really pretty
[Laughter]
they would say it they would say it back
and then never be like thanks and I'm
like oh just like just imagine being the
translator and just like that's less a
next level of third wheel the whole
thing is like obviously I'm also
drinking a lot of alcohol cuz the main
host was adamant on getting me smashed
yeah and so it looked like we were
drinking water but it was just like
shorty in between the shots that you
were constantly doing was strong zero oh
God and they would drink strong zero
like I said worldwide they every every
time they'd have to go to a girl they
would have to finish all that drink they
would make as well those were always
like 12% or high spirits right and this
I remember they were telling me the
hosts in Japan they were like like
vomiting every single night from alcohol
I mean if you're mixing strong zero like
champagne and sham shots yeah cuz they
made me download like a half bottle of
champagne oh my god how much was that
world how much that there on the menu it
costs like I think it was like nine
thousand or something were you sick
after no I wasn't lyin up I went to like
a little lamb right after a night a
great meal so bring up in a vault but
yeah so that was like nine you drank
like $4,000 worth of champagne yeah and
then a bunch of drinks in between that
the shots were like thirty dollars each
and the drinks were like $50 each would
you ever do a video like that Chris well
I was thinking about doing it so I saw
yours I'm not gonna put myself that's
what I thought
I wondered why no J vloggers had done it
but I felt like none of them would be
willing to do yeah I'm not cutting like
five years of my life expectancy
I think right they do it but like they
all owned like apartments in central
Shinjuku because they make like average
like $10,000 yeah yeah yeah like and a
lot of them sent its their family so a
lot of them are just like making them
money while it's good I guess and they
are getting out that the coolest guy
there was the vice-president who like
wasn't a Hearst and I thought he was
like my father hardest as well he was
like 34 he looked like every like bishi
anime account okay yeah and he was
really nice he was reopen he was giving
us a whole tour Chun is everything about
the club I'll see other guys just wanted
to see me fail with the women cuz they I
remember the main guy was like oh yeah
yeah yeah you're gonna you're gonna be
supporting me and I turn I in the house
I go over and he's like oh yes oh no you
have to do though I'll support you I'm
like what I was lied to
yeah and we cut a lot of the stuff cuz I
got really [ __ ] drunk what's like the
what's like the craziest place you're
like willing to like go film in Japan
I've always wanted film the snack bar or
hostess bar because you've done there
are they it's basically what you've just
described but the other way around with
girls and guys okay far less expensive
are where I used to live in Yamagata
it's like the only thing to do you go to
another kind the second place you always
go for new xico party is hostess club or
snack bars can like a cheaper variant
I've been to a snack bar before yeah and
there's nothing seedy about them there's
no cd about hosts I mean it was a little
bit seedy for me cuz almost like 1600 in
the middle of nowhere in Hokkaido cuz I
was working in ski fields and my boss
was like hey let's go to snack bar and
I'm like I'm like four years on you know
there's like 16 year old kids just like
sitting there you know just like
sleeping you know beer or whatever and
the mama who's like a who's that's the
name that they give to like that the
main hostess of the snack bar yeah yeah
she just sat right next to me she's like
so how old are you my boss at the time I
was like shit-faced already cuz he
couldn't hold his liquor he's like oh
he's 26 and and at the moment he said
that I was like I'm getting kicked out
there's no way she's gonna look at me
and be like yeah you're 26 year old but
no the mom I just looked at me was like
oh you look for a young 26 year old it's
apparent if you say you're over 20 then
quest
no like I'm cool cuz cuz like in Asia
especially like if you're is because you
cuz you're like half Australian as well
so they just assume you're [ __ ] old as
[ __ ] thankful for my yeah yeah yes I was
like thank god I look like five years
older than I actually am yes I would
have been some deep [ __ ] otherwise but
no but the stuff was fun like it's way
more chill than like what I assume a
host club would be easy I mean you just
sit down I have to take friends to one
just to Surprise them it comes to Pam
for the first time because they sit down
and there's like two girls are the sides
and then I pull that drinks like their
cigarettes most of my friends are
awkward because it's a concept that
doesn't exist really you know cuz yeah I
think I think yeah I would describe
doubt someone in the UK I think they
would think that's kind of like I mean
the closest thing I could think of in
like the UK is probably like a strip
club that's that's thought but no but
it's I'm not saying that is but it's
like the closest experience I can think
of just for like a very broad term
hostess place cuz I won't be really you
know they'll talk to you so much yeah
and then they'll make you sing karaoke
songs that's right they might make you
drink a disturbing amount of noise bad
yeah they definitely seem really sleazy
the host clubs and I believe that's like
a lot of them are owned by you know
sketchy people those people I'm free
sure I'm pretty sure a lot of them are
owned by that because they just kind of
like operate under their own yeah I mean
that's where I was so impressed that
they were just wanna be like yeah come
on in film it all man yeah I don't know
how you got permission though that that
easily what happened connection is that
yeah I think our producer Maylene best
best producer has every connection Japan
apparently talked to a host host was
like yeah I want to start my youtube
channel so that and them that and
apparently if you're like the number one
host in the club you have a lot of like
yeah that's constantly changing so next
week you could be like have no say right
so this guy was like oh yeah I'm
bringing this guy with a film crew take
care of him and to be fair everyone
really like nicely that does film a lot
of stuff like how they when they were
talked about earnings in South it was
film but we cut that but they let us
light in on listening to it and who was
winning the eggs and stuff and they take
it really seriously they compete against
other host clubs to see who's getting
the most money between them and we're
talking like disturbing amounts of money
like I think one guy for is the one who
gets the most is Roland I think right
yeah no okay cuz okay on one one one guy
for his birthday they were telling me he
got like $60,000 on his birthday your
birthday for us to buy you drinks and
stuff we're in the wrong business
they asked me you know they asked me
like how much you earned for like having
a million subscribers in like a month
and they were like that it knows if
you're starting YouTube channel for the
money don't bother just it was at that
moment that I've never regretted but not
speaking Japanese yeah any moment ah
[ __ ] just come in here like part-time
you know what I mean they're like
they're like oh you're on $1 per
subscriber right that's that's that's
how I watch that's how the YouTube
economy works all right
I've never like I thought like I don't
nice comfy earning until they like just
[ __ ] in front of all the hosts right
wow that's pathetic that's cute that's
cute yeah